anlässlich des jubiläumsjahres 60 jahre
österreichisches bundesheer hat die
münze österreich eine 5 euro münze unter
dem titel bundesheer schutz und hilfe
aufgelegt die präsentation der münze
fand am 6 mai 2015 im rahmen einer
spektakulären vorführung des
jagdkommandos mit den luftstreitkräften
statt
fallschirmspringer des jagdkommandos
übergaben die münze an den
generaldirektor der münze österreich
generaldirektor magister starsich
überreichte bundesminister magister club
die münze sehr geehrter herr
generaldirektor ich danke ihnen und
ihren mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern
dass das jubiläum 60 jahre
österreichisches bundesheer durch diese
sondermünze nicht nur österreichweit
sondern auch international beachtung
finden wird
interessierte gäste und journalisten
nutzten die möglichkeit ein flug mit dem
black hawk zu machen
ganz toll für mich das erlebnis mit
blick hoch zufrieden ein gefühl zu
gewinnen
geburtstag zeitung namens lord oder
weihnacht ich bin ja ein ein bundesheer
vorher ich weiß auch dass man diese alle
diese dinge die hier vorgeführt wurde im
krisenfall einsetzen kann
daher haben wir das schon verbreitung es
ist einmal james bond es ist besser was
er ist
das ist so ein angenehmes verkehrsmittel
ich will einen haben
ich brenne schon darauf meinen freunden
davon zu erzählen was ich heute erleben
durfte